let's give ourselves a little bit more
practice with discrete probability
distributions or probability mass
functions so let's define our random
variable let's just call it X again and
let's say it's equal to the role of a
fair six-sided dice six-sided die so
just a regular type of die that you
would use to play Monopoly or something
like that let's draw its probability
distribution I encourage you to try to
draw it on your own before you see how I
draw it so let's on the vertical axis
here so the vertical axis here this is
going to be the probability that we get
any particular outcome and then over
here or the probability good each
outcome here we're going to put all the
outcomes so the values that X can take
on are going to be you could get a 1 you
could get a 2 a 3 a 4 a 5 and a 6 now
what's the probability of getting a 1 if
you roll a fair six-sided die well it's
one of six equally likely outcomes so
you have a 1/6 probability so it's 1/6
so that's the probability of getting a 1
I'll draw it as a little bar chart here
so you have a 1/6 probability of getting
a 1 now what's the probability of
getting a 2 well once again it's one out
of six equally likely outcomes so it's
once again 1/6 so I'll just draw it just
like that it is 1/6 again and same thing
for 3 it's one of 6 equally possible
outcomes so there's a 1/6 probability of
getting a 3 there's a 1/6 probability of
getting a 4 there is a 1/6 probability
of getting a 5 and there is a 1/6
probability 1/6 probability of getting a
6 my little markers here got a little
bit off-center but hopefully you get the
general idea so that's 5 and that is 6
now the way that I've drawn it right
here is this a legitimate probability
distribution well sure it is you see
that you have 6 equal
likely outcomes each of them have a 1/6
probability of occurring the total the
total I guess you could say mass here if
you say that there's 1/6 in each of
these buckets it's 6 times 1/6 it's 1 it
all adds up to 1 which makes sense you
have a one or a hundred percent
probability of getting one of these
outcomes when you roll a fair six-sided
die now when you have a probability
distribution where every outcome is
equally likely like this so notice every
outcome is equally likely there's a word
for it just so you know it in the future
if someone says that you are dealing
with a uniform a uniform a uniform
distribution distribution and you could
have a discrete uniform distribution
that's what we have in this case and in
future videos we're also going to see
continuous uniform distributions now my
question to you let's say that someone
took one of these six sided die and
erased erased one of the so you have one
side of the die that looks something
like this where it has two dots on it
and someone was able to erase it so that
so that side only has one sided so now
we're not doing we're not going to deal
with the role of a fair six-sided die
it's still going to be a six-sided die
but it's no longer fair anymore
it's no longer fair anymore it's the two
side to side replaced replaced with with
another one side another one so you have
two sides of the six-sided die that are
r1 and then you have no side that has a
two on it and then the rest haven't been
changed you have a three or four or five
and a six side for this random variable
what would the probability distribution
now look like I encourage you to draw it
right now so you might guess that it
will no longer be uniform so let me
remove this just so we don't get
confused and let's think about it what's
the probability for this for this new
die that I get a 1 well there's now two
possible ways that I can get out
one out of six so there's now a 2/6
probability that I get a one so let me
draw that
it's now a 2/6 probability that I get a
1 so it looks like this all shaded in so
this right over here is 2 6 or I could
write that as 1/3 if I like now what's
the probability of getting a 2 well it's
impossible for me to get a 2 now there
is no 2 on this die I've removed the 2
it's now 1 so there's nothing here let
me delete all of this there is nothing
here I have no probability I cannot get
a 2 no face of this die has a 2 now
what's the probability of getting a 3 4
5 or 6
well those are unchanged there's still a
1 side that has a three out of six
equally likely sides so you have a 1/6
probability of a 3 a 4 a 5 or a 6 so the
rest the rest stays unchanged so once
again we've constructed another discrete
probability distribution it is no longer
uniform and it's a little bit more
interesting this is the role of this not
so fair six-sided die you have two sides
that have a 1 on it and no side that has
a 2